hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
fantasy and romance movie called it's a
boy girl thing
the film begins with woody and nelly
they are neighbors and former childhood
friends who go to the same high school
one night woody plays music at a loud
volume which makes nelly annoyed and
angry with him because woody doesn't
want to turn the music down she gets
angry and immediately closes the window
unfortunately her clothes get stuck in
the window making woody see nellie's
naked body
they have very different habits
woody is a popular varsity football
player while nelly is a girl who loves
literature but lacks social skills
they loathe each other and are
constantly in dispute when woody wants
to go to school he is picked up by his
friend harry while nelly walks to school
because she missed the school bus
while walking woody and harry
intentionally pass a puddle of water
which made nellie's body drenched
nellie's appearance looked disheveled
when she arrived at the school
as a result woody's girlfriend brianna
laughs at her in the school hallways
woody also pretends to apologize to her
nelly eventually decides to ignore them
in the classroom woody idly types
obscene things on nelly's computer that
makes a loud noise causing all the
students in the class to laugh at her
later their class goes on a school trip
to an ancient museum
woody and nelly are forced to work
together on an assignment because of it
they quickly begin arguing in front of a
statue of the ancient statue as they
argue the statue quietly casts a spell
upon them
at night the spell works on their bodies
causing them to wake up in each other's
bodies the next morning
when they wake up they panic because
their bodies have swapped last night
they are also very confused with each
other's habits when they arrive at
school they immediately blame each other
for the body swap but agree to pretend
to be the other person until they can
find a way to switch back
at first they seem to succeed but
quickly return to arguing when they each
feel the other is misrepresenting them
in the opposite body such as woody
answering a question oddly from the
teacher
later nellie also humiliates woody's
body in the cafeteria by dropping his
food
inevitably she has to join the football
practice because woody is the leader of
his team
however she doesn't know what to do
causing the coach to scold her for the
poor performance on the pitch
the next day it turns out that their
bodies are still swapped and have not
returned woody sees nelly is wearing
neat clothes making woody's appearance
look dorky which frustrates him he is
even more frustrated after he hears
about how nelly failed woody's football
practice the previous day as payback
woody dresses in inappropriate and
provocative clothing to the school the
following day he also intentionally
makes nellie's reputation worse
after school nelly in retaliation breaks
up with brianna much to the
disappointment of woody
furthermore the humiliation competition
continues when woody drives off with a
biker boy nicki and makes nellie think
she is going to lose her virginity
however woody thinks that it feels so
wrong because he's a man inside a
woman's body and not completely a woman
he then decides to leave nikki
the next morning rumors are being spread
around the school by nikki about his
night with nelly when she overhears
about it she gets very upset
soon woody finds nelly at the school
corridor he admits that he didn't
actually lose nellie's virginity and
that everyone was simply spreading
nicki's lies nonetheless nelly is still
let down and so woody decides to
confront nicki it turns out that woody
can't fight him because he is inside
nellie's body but at the right time
nelly runs up and punches nicki in the
face
forcing him to admit all his lies
afterwards woody is worried that his
football match will be held soon
suddenly they realize that before their
bodies were swapped they argued in front
of an ancient statue which turns out to
be an ancient aztec god tescotlipoca
nelly and woody reach a truce and they
immediately head down to the museum
sadly they failed to return to their
original bodies after confronting the
statue they then realized that they are
going to have to help each other in two
important upcoming events nelly must
learn how to play football for woody's
upcoming match and woody must learn
about poetry and literature for nelly's
upcoming interview later that night
nelly is getting drunk at a party with
harry while woody is stuck at a slumber
party with nelly's friends listening to
all the gossip about himself
he is also surrounded by nail polish
pajamas and gets a bikini wax
later woody takes care of nelly who is
dizzy from last night's hangover after
spending so much time together they
become very fond of each other and start
to understand each other better the
night before the interview and the game
they agree to go to the school party
together as not a date
the day of the interview and match woody
goes for the interview he initially
messes things up and is asked to leave
but he starts to talk about poetry and
rap which impresses and astonishes the
interviewer
after that he goes to the football game
and watches nelly run in the winning
touchdown in the closing seconds
a college recruiter witnesses her good
performance and wants to talk to her
later after the game they congratulate
each other for their successes
they sincerely have forgiven each other
and said similar words is when they were
arguing in front of the ancient statue
shortly after this the spell lifts and
they eventually return to their original
bodies the scene finishes with woody
being kissed by brianna and nelly going
home because she is very upset seeing it
soon woody tries to invite nellie to the
school party but he is stopped by her
mother who sees woody's family as
uneducated nelly then receives an
acceptance letter from the university
meaning that her interview which was
done by woody and her body earlier was
successful however she is still upset
with woody and decides not to go to the
school party meanwhile nelly's father
has a talk with her on the porch about
woody during which she confesses she
truly likes him and her father surprises
her with a dress and shoes for the party
on the other hand woody and brianna are
selected as the school king and queen
as they prepare to dance woody suddenly
sees nellie and both confess their love
for each other straight away
in the end they leave the school
together and share a kiss in front of
their houses as their father secretly
cheers for them together
the following day nelly tells her mother
that she is taking a year's sabbatical
before attending the university and she
hops into woody's cars that drive off
together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching